[Musique]
Anthony nous sommes le 2 avril date
importante pour tous les amateurs de
football noté depuis longtemps dans les
agendas rencontre sommet le
parissaggermain qui retrouve Barcelone
en Ligue des Champions et c'est un peu
le département des ivelines qui sera
dans la lumière tout à l'heure oui tout
à fait à 2h du choc toute la France du
football attend et notamment les les
ivelines puisque le camp des Loges se
trouve à Saint-Germain en lait dans le
département et bien nous nous allons
vous dévoiler tout simplement les
coulisses de ce match nous étions hier
au Camp des Loges puis au Parc des
Princes pour les conférences de presse
ce récit avec des images de Claire
cambille au Parc des Princes David
Beckham n'a pas montré le bout de son
nez pourtant la salle de conférence
était pleine comme un œuf l'attaquant du
PSG Zlatan Ibrahimovic prenant le relais
devant les micros une question
d'expérience de ces rencontres au sommet
comme ce quart de finale de Ligue des
Champions face à Barcelone souvent
transparent lors des grands matchs le
meilleur buteur de Ligue 1 ne devra pas
se louper face à son ancien
club je pense que ce sera un match très
difficile car on va affronter la
meilleure équipe et probablement la
meilleure de tous les
temps et on sait très bien que Barcelone
a garder le ballon mais mais nous aurons
des occasions car nous jouons à
domicile alors comment gagner face à la
meilleure équipe du monde et surtout
arrêter Lionel Messi le quadruple Ballon
d'Or hauteur déjà de 56 cette saison il
faudra certainement imiter le Milan au
tour précédent et défendre en bloc quoi
qu'il en soit Carlo Ancelotti ne compte
pas changer ses plans tactiques espère
voir le meilleur de ses joueurs contre
Barça difficile poures les
équipes je voudrais
voir paris-germain courage avec
personnalité qu'elle va jouer le match
peut-être que nous avons pas beaucoup de
possession quand nous avons la
possession j'espère de voir équipe qu'il
a des bonnes idées clair pour jouer pour
attaquer pour marquer pour
gagnerelques plus grand match de le vie
less parisgermain SEM serein rire et
descraction rgent à l'entraînement
davidam é une nouvelle fois le premier
sur le terrain au du Camp des Loges à
Saint-Germain plusieurs dizaines de
passionnés les attendent et malgré
l'vereste qui se dress devant le PSG il
y cro j'èrejil
surout nos chances pour le match retour
qu'on garde des chances au moins ne pas
perdre ne pas perdre serait déjà bien
comme ça on garde des chances pour le
match retour puis ensuite on sait jamais
contre le Barça moi je pense qu'il faut
faut faut jouer si on est trop derrière
on a vu le Milan jouer derrière en ont
pris quatre en fait faut jouer faut
jouer faut pas avoir peur d'eux faut
jouer les presser au milieu en fait moi
je pense ça va être un match dur ça va
être difficile mais c'est pas impossible
si on j les coups à fond il y a pas de
raison qu'on perde mais ouais ça va pas
être facile demain je pense ce soir les
joueurs de Carlo ancelonti sentiront
sûrement le poids de l'Histoire celle
d'un club qui ne sissait qu'une seule
fois en quart de finale de la Coupe
d'Europe c'était en
1995 et le PSG qui avait gagné à Paris
d'ailleurs he oui tout à fait face à
Barcelone il y a eu il y a eu un
précédent face un but de Vincent Guérin
voilà que l'histoire va se répéter ce
soir on l'espère quel est votre
pronostic pour ce soir un petit 1-0
quand même on va rester chauin on va
voir si les cquantinois les ivelinois
partagent votre avis micro trottoir
votre pronostic pour le match de ce
soir dans le foot est possible après
forcément le Barça reste
favori
maintenant le Barça a des difficultés
actuellement en défense surtout dans
l'axe alors pourquoi pas pareil un petit
match nul pour commencer D 3 pour Barça
pourquoi parce que même s'il y a Zlatan
dans le PSG ou David Beckam ils font pas
le poids face à face à Messi face à piqu
et toute la clique moi je vois un 32 je
sais pas pourquoi 32 pour j'espère pour
le PSG ce sera le PSG qui va gagner
et avec Zlatan Ibrahimovic je pense ça
fera du bien que que Zlatan Zlatan se pr
une bonne racé donc je pense que c'est
le Barça qui va gagner Barcelone va
gagner 2-0 doublé de Lionel Messi tout
va jouer au match retour donc pourquoi
pas une victoire mais une courte
victoire de Paris
1-0